illegal border crossings like the one
you have shown right here in this video
hitting an all-time high and now in an
effort to curb it President Biden and
DHS will now allow some Central
Americans and Colombians with family
here to enter legally really our next
guest knows all about the growing surge
of illegal Crossings at the border
Lieutenant Chris Olivares joins us now
with the Texas Department of Public
Safety so if you have a citizen you're
from Guatemala if you're from El
Salvador Lieutenant you can now come
here is that correct
that's correct according to this policy
but Brian you know this is going to be a
complete disaster it's not going to stop
you know Mass migration and one thing
that the American people don't
understand or it's really not being
transparent from the federal government
is that yes numbers have declined you
know between the ports events as far as
the number of encounters but a lot of
these illegal immigrants are being
released at the ports of Entry so
essentially the federal government is
legalizing illegal immigration and all
it's going to do is create a much larger
magnet for people to make their way to
the United States because they know for
a fact that they have family they have
friends that have been released to the
country as mentioned in this policy and
all it's going to do is create a much
larger backlog in the future when you
have millions and millions of people in
the country right now that are going to
have to wait for Asylum hearing so
they're going to get lost in the system
that's not going to stop the problem
that we're seeing at the border right
and they're just going to pray for a big
amnesty where some politician just
finally gives way so this is to me a
thing logically it's going to be a surge
at the border suddenly people go wait we
could go we have an and you know we have
an aunt in Columbia in in Columbus
Georgia you know we we can go and now
all of a sudden they're going to come
there and they have a reason to do it
this seems to be a magnet
it does Brian also too to keep in mind
too now we don't know exactly how this
process is going to work what type of
bedding is going to be taking place to
actually know or prove that they
actually have family members or
relatives in the country we see that
abuse right now with the Asylum process
with you know with uh legal immigrants
using children as a Gateway into the
country and of course A lot of these are
not being better they're not being
processed so we don't even know if
they're actual family members but again
they aren't being released they're being
processed into the country just think
about the thousands of children and
those that have already been released in
the country right now exactly we don't
know where they're at and how and what
the process is going to be in the future
so this is going to be uh just a
complete disaster it's not going to help
the problem at the border it's going to
continue to create more people to come
make this long treacherous journey and
all it's going to do really like I said
mention it's a really high the negative
Optics where you don't have thousands
coming across between the ports
eventually but behind that you're going
to have thousands that have been
released at the ports of Entry
Lieutenant real quick uh I know Governor
Abbotts is going to put these buoys
starting so overseeing the installation
of these buoys in the Rio Grande what is
it he's supposed to be doing and how do
you think it could stop uh the influx
what brightness another unprecedented to
move by the state of Texas you know we
we started and with operation Lone Star
back in 2021
um we have thousands of Troopers
National Guard at the border since then
we've installed miles and miles of
concertina water barrier shifting
containers Texas border wall now with
the first ever historic Marine barrier
that's getting placed in the Rio Grande
River this is going to help curb illegal
immigration those that are crossing
between the ports of Entry it's going to
prevent Smugglers from bringing people
across and also most important it's
going to prevent the loss of life the
number of deaths drownings that have
been taking place during the Fourth of
July holiday our Troopers recovered four
bodies including an infant that drowned
in the river so it makes it very
dangerous so again this is going to help
let's hear that yeah more Texas dollars
doing something the federal government
should be doing uh Lieutenant Chris
Olivares thanks so much I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis